sur mes arguments qu'on n'a pas pu faire
partir là bas tu ne prends plus les
collines de plus de 15 kilos d'autres
bouteilles doivent aussi impossible
d'envoyer des colis de plus de 15 kilos
une difficulté supplémentaire pour ce
couple de vignerons se sont en effet les
ventes aux particuliers qui leur
permettent jusqu'à maintenant de sauver
les meubles alors que leur chiffre
d'affaires a chuté de plus de 90% jeu
fournisseurs et les prestataires en ce
moment c'est un vrai problème c'est à
dire que ce qui lèverait à l'instant t
les plus une heure après là en fait
vendredi dernier la poste nous a rappelé
nous a appelé en disant que l'on pouvait
de nouveau envoyer des colis
puisque la poste a été fermé plusieurs
jours ici et en finalité est vrai que
d'une journée sur l'autre aile et les
conditions sont plus les mêmes
les conseils sont plus les mêmes enfin
bref et puis il est pas question de
décevoir un client un jour ils peuvent
vivre et les particuliers le normand ils
peuvent plus problème c'est quand on a
fait une promesse un client faut qu'on
la respecte pas faim chez nous c'est
comme ça autre conséquence de la
situation sanitaire
christine et vincent sevillano ont été
contraints de retarder la mise en
bouteille de champagne
or il faut absolument libérer les cuves
avant les vendanges pour pouvoir y
mettre la nouvelle cuvée il espère avoir
la possibilité de le faire en début
d'été on l'a décalé fin juin en espérant
voilà avoir déjà au niveau matériel
sécuritaire un peu plus de disponibilité
notamment pour nos équipes et pour nous
mêmes parce que la mise en bouteille se
fait dans la cave
donc on va être une quinzaine de
personnes à proximité donc il est hors
de question de faire une mise en
bouteille si on n'est pas protégé on
peut pas protéger nos équipes ces vins
là au minimum doivent être gardées 15
mois pour pouvoir les commercialiser
donc plus on met en bouteille tard et
plus ce délai est reporté donc si demain
on est en rupture de stock sur une de
nos gammes et que voit le délai n'est
pas arrivée en camion pourra pas sortir
ses valeurs les conditions du
déconfinement sont encore floues et il
ne semble pas que les bars et les
restaurants
parmi les principaux clients de ces
vignerons rouvre de sitôt à l'heure
actuelle les pertes du domaine piot
sevillano sont donc difficiles à estimer
c'est compliqué il y en aura une c'est
sûr au niveau des volumes si on voit
bien que il n'y a pas beaucoup de volume
de bouteilles qui sortent ça soit tous
les opérateurs dès que l'écran de
maisons ont mis tout leur système à
l'arrêt donc il y aura une perte que me
rattrapable contrat va être compliqué
parce que ce qui n'est pas vendu 1
restant cab l'heure est pour le moment à
la préparation des huit hectares de
vignes à vendanger une tâche à laquelle
s'attelle solène et ses collègues en
s'adaptant aux mesures de distanciation
sociale on a deux camions donc on évite
de se coller dans les camions y en a 1
derrière un devant en eux tout seuls
dans un autre camion puis vous voyez
bien que quand on est au vignon
touche pas on a vraiment beaucoup de
distance de sécurité entre nous c'est
toute l'organisation de la saison 2020
des vendanges qui est pour le moment
remise en question normalement c'est
septembre et cette année avec la
végétation qui est en avance ça va être
même peut-être fin août
mais ces trente personnes qu'on embauche
et puis qu'on loge et qu'on nourrit et
étant donné circonstances on sait pas
très bien dans quelles conditions pour
l'instant chaque année ce sont environ
50 mille bouteilles qui sortent du
domaine
mais le cru 2020 sera certainement bien
en deçà de ses standards habituels